how's it going bros my name is I have
not changed my shirt in four days let's
watch some tick tocks
good job good job
joking
what the [ __ ] is a budger budget honest
I [ __ ] love budget yeah
what is that a bagger a bird yeah he's
got his own fan page now it's a bird he
said a bird honest
who loves birds so much yes yes yes
my man
oh like
[Laughter]
stop Yes okay this is great because I
got this in my feed and I wrote Jack
because I thought it was funny he had
watched the trailer where this is cool
shot that happens after this and he was
trying to set that up but I guess he let
go
the fact that he tried to make it cool
makes it even funnier
it's like that anime closed cams at the
moment scenes you can punch the softest
you first
that's it
you win
[Laughter]
children are evil how can they do this
domestic abused from a child
my person made us do have video response
for a discussion boarding
my apologies for the earlier segment I
have no idea how to delete it
what is she doing I gotta see that again
my sincerest apologies for what you just
saw Psy would not cut that out of the
video
Dave's
[Laughter]
I forgot about it it's so good
contract taste contact tasting testing
all right I'm getting Boris not being
able to speak now
things almost no humans can do but I'm
not sure and if you come then you're
bloody weird this is where you bend your
pinky finger like this and only five
percent of humans can actually do this
what is this saying can you speak
English please
oh it's difficult
yeah
that camp that can't be it you're bloody
you're bloody way wine car logged its
first
between two airports they did it
Slovakia this week
speed of about 106 miles per hour it can
raise Heights of about 8 200 feet think
that's cool check this out it can
transforms into a car in two minutes
seconds I waited so long I waited too
long I'm almost I'm not even excited I
waited too long I don't care no you took
too long you had your chance 50 years
ago when I wasn't even born you dumbass
this lady keeps stealing my mail I
a lot of coming
trucks in this neighborhood what about
what about a lot of packages coming to
this house particular well something's
going we're having a [ __ ] pocket
Amazon
excuse me
oh
it's fake I guess you know even though
it's fake the fact that this could 100
be real makes it funny still so it
passed it passes
oh yeah
that's a response
yes sir come on
please
I will not speak to you woman until you
give me my supper
I want some pork meow meow what did
people use to wipe their butts okay
warning warning this is awful before
toilet paper so ancient Greeks use
little bits of pottery some of them even
had their enemies names written on them
I feel like I heard about that yeah but
how I asked much about this she does
Potter and she's like yeah they might
soak it up if it's
unglazed things were known as astraka
they were used to vote for someone to be
kicked out of a town which is where we
get the word ostracized from the Romans
would use sponges mounted a sticks which
don't look so bad I'll I'll stick that
in my ass Until you realize they shared
them they just kind of hell yeah
that's the dream we had it we had
Perfection restrooms with no souls in
them we need to bring it back Hey listen
I know you think it's weird but we pee
next to each other right huh shlong
right there why can't we poo next to
each other
why give me one good reason you can't
there are none there are no good reasons
this this is the society we live in this
is what we could live in and we could be
sharing poo sticks maybe not that part
the Japanese using chugi also known as a
[ __ ] stick I'm not because this is the
name of the Wikipedia article it's what
it's called they were exactly what they
sound like other parts of the world just
used water and many still do which parts
because they are clearly the right ones
what the [ __ ] else would you use
Americans use dried corn options use
dried corn cobs or Pages the Farmer's
Almanac the book even started coming
with a pre-drilled hole to hang in your
Outhouse that can't be true you're
telling me before people white with
paper they use an element
China invented toilet paper in the 500s
but the rest of the world had to wait
until the 19th century and it wasn't
until 1935 that splinter free toilet
paper Splinter three nice those flinters
in my anus yummy yummy this is honestly
the bottom line of mold avoidance we can
debate all day long but in the end mold
avoidance takes many of us from sick to
hiking mountains mold avoid it avoid the
mold
because we can go on top of Mounds if
you avoid them what the [ __ ] is this
what is it that's an image you
understand you're not making a before
and after you did sick to pick get it
out with anything
are you on about what what what's mold
what mold is there what is he talking
about this is satire I can't tell I'm
lost can someone please explain this to
me mold avoidance saved my life well
avoidance yeah people aren't talking
about mold avoidance uh like they should
be doing obviously it's been known for
decades that mold spores cause an
inflammatory response inflammatory
response in the brain is associated with
depression that's right if you have
depression uh you're not avoiding
avoiding mold you [ __ ] dummy hello
stop being sad walk away from mold idiot
now the real question is why the [ __ ] is
Tick Tock putting this [ __ ] in my feed
oh this is nice I like a wholesome Tick
Tock thank you I don't get it he didn't
jump or nothing you ruining okay Boomers
rumors did this
[Music]
they put concrete on it
why
who would do that
[Music]
that's insane another crazy thing here
uh Arab buildings that were torn down
for whatever reason rumors did it I
blame Boomers
wow
where the [ __ ] did you come from you
could have just added a text wow so
smart I love this
[ __ ] JD it jumpscare pretty dude jump
scare
[Music]
a cheeseburger
um he was the PIP of the party until he
ordered a cheeseburger all right this
one is so weird okay I can't tell if she
says 14 or four you tell me because it's
weird it's How We Do bath time for my 14
year old gamer obsessed sir she says 14.
I'm 40 mama my mama ain't making bad for
me all right we have a minions drink
specially then we have all his favorite
toys gaming toys and a minion colored
bath bomb
then it just hit me that maybe the kid
is like special needs or something that
now I feel bad but right top ready for
him to play
all these things and you know what he's
gonna love it nah
nah
okay let's try and have some empathy all
right you don't know if everyone's
situation she's getting ready come on
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
give him the area
he gets a little blanket
[Music]
a little piggy blanket
[Music]
[Applause]
I did this I did this remarks yet and
she was like oh and then two seconds
later she's like you saw that on Tick
Tock didn't you
[Music]
hell yeah that's always sad look at the
speed
let's go
hell yeah
so cute
amazing
but bro you're not you're not pressing
it down all the way right okay it was in
the McDonald's
the same features also this
let's go
[Applause]
oh my gods
oh my God now that's a conspiracy right
there
[Music]
I don't even like cats but they're so
funny
uh all right I'm gonna end it there
thanks for watching guys subscribe leave
a like and maybe I'll have a new clean
shirt for next video check it out
brofist